[Music]
four years ago
softbank founder masayoshi sun stormed
into britain
and bought uk chip designer arm holdings
in the country's biggest ever tech deal
for 32 billion dollars coming a week
after the uk voted to leave the eu
the transaction was held by some
politicians as an example of continued
investor interest from international
companies
despite brexit mr sun declared arm to be
a crystal ball
that would guide him to make investments
in everything from artificial
intelligence to the internet of things
with arm under his control the japanese
billionaire investor
quickly convinced backers in saudi
arabia and abu dhabi to pour tens of
billions of dollars into a new
hundred billion dollar fund called the
vision fund which would focus on
startups
but the investors only joined on the
condition that a slice of arm was moved
into the fund
four years later mr sun's crystal ball
has yielded few results
under softbank's ownership arm failed to
thrive and the vision fund which became
known for a series of aggressive bets on
startups including wework
and wag hasn't turned out quite as he
would have hoped
meanwhile other chip companies did much
better than arm
one of those us-based nvidia was worth
only 30 billion dollars when softbank
acquired the uk company
but by the time nvidia decided it was
interested in buying arm in the summer
of 2020
its market value had surpassed 300
billion by september
nvidia agreed to pay up to 40 billion
dollars for arm
it's not a done deal though uk
politicians are clamoring for
commitments from nvidia to keep some of
arm's operations in britain
longer term the transaction will also
require clearance from places such as
china which may look to scupper the deal
as part of its ongoing spat with the u.s
over sensitive technology
for softbank though the crystal ball
upon which mr sun had staked the
company's future is gone
the question is what comes next for
softbank and its investors